let's start at the beginning what is the
origin story of Wikipedia the origin
story of Wikipedia well so I was
watching the growth of the free software
movement open source software and seeing
programmers coming together to
collaborate in new ways uh sharing code
doing that under free license which is
really interesting because it empowers
an ability to work together that's
really hard to do if the code is still
proprietary because then if I chip in
and help we sort of have to figure out
how I'm going to be rewarded and what
that is but the idea that everyone can
copy it and it just is part of the
commons uh really empowered a huge wave
of uh
creative software production and I
realized that that kind of collaboration
could extend beyond just software to all
kinds of cultural works and the first
thing that I thought of was an
encyclopedia and I thought oh that seems
obvious that an encyclopedia you can
collaborate on it there's a few reasons
why one we all pretty much know what an
encyclopedia entry on say the Eiffel
Tower should be like you know you should
see a picture a few pictures maybe
history location
something about the architect et cetera
Etc so we have a shared understanding of
what it is we're trying to do and then
we can collaborate and different people
can chip in and find sources and so on
and so forth so set up first new pedia
which was about two years before
Wikipedia and with newpedia we we had
this idea that
um in order to be respected we had to be
even more academic than a traditional
encyclopedia
because a bunch of volunteers on the
internet getting out of the right an
encyclopedia you know you could be made
fun of if it's just every random person
so we had implemented this seven stage
review process to get anything published
um and two two things came of that so
one thing one of the earliest entries
that we published after this rigorous
process
a few days later we had to pull it
because as soon as it hit the web and
the broader Community took a look at it
uh people noticed plagiarism and
realized that it it wasn't actually that
good even though it had been reviewed by
academics and so on so we had to pull it
so it's like okay well so much for seven
stage review process but also I decided
that I wanted to try I was frustrated
and why is this taking so long why is it
so hard
so I thought okay I saw that uh Robert
Merton had won a Nobel prize in
economics for his work on option pricing
Theory and when I was in Academia that's
what I worked on was option pricing
Theory how to publish paper so I'd
worked through all of his academic
papers and I knew his work quite well
I thought oh I'll just I'll write a
short biography of Merton
and when I started to do it I'd been out
of Academia I had been a grad student
for a few years then I felt this huge
intimidation because they were going to
take my draft and send it to the most
prestigious Finance professors that we
could find to give me feedback for
revisions and it felt like being back in
grad school you know it's like this
really oppressive sort of like you're
going to submit it for a review and
you're going to get critiques a little
bit the bad part of God yeah yeah the
bad part of grad school right and so I
was like oh this isn't intellectually
fun this is like the bad part of grad
school it's intimidating and there's a
lot of
um you know potential embarrassment if I
screw something up and so forth and so
that was when I realized okay look this
is never going to work this is not
something that people are really going
to want to do
so Jeremy Rosenfeld one of my employees
had brought and showed me the wiki
Concept in December and then Larry
Sanger brought in uh the same said what
about this Wiki idea and so uh in
January we decided to launch Wikipedia
but we weren't sure so the original
project was called newpedia and even
though it wasn't successful we did have
quite a group of academics and like
really serious people and we were
concerned that oh maybe these academics
are going to really hate this idea and
we shouldn't just convert the project
immediately we should launch this as a
side project the idea of here's a Wiki
where we can start playing around
but actually we got more work done in
two weeks than we had in almost two
years because people were able to just
jump on and start doing stuff and it was
actually a very exciting time you know
you could back then you could be the
first person who typed Africa as a
continent and hit say if you know which
isn't much of an encyclopedia entry but
it's true and it's a start and it's kind
of fun like I you know you put your name
down actually a funny story was uh
several years later I just happened to
be online and I saw when um I think his
name is Robert Allman won the Nobel
prize in economics and we didn't have an
entry uh on him at all which was
surprising but it wasn't that surprising
this was still early days you know
um and so I got to be the first person
to type Robert Allman won Nobel prize in
economics and hit save which again
wasn't a very good article but then I
came back two days later and people had
improved it and so forth so that that
second half of the experience where with
Robert Merton I never succeeded because
it was just too intimidating it was like
oh no I was able to chip in and help
other people jumped in everybody was
interested in the topic because it's all
in the news at the moment and so it's
just a completely different model which
worked much much better well what is it
that made that so accessible so fun so
uh so natural to just add something well
I think it's you know especially in the
early days and this by the way has
gotten much harder because there are
fewer topics that are just Green Field
you know available
um but you know you could say oh well I
you know I know a little bit about this
and I can I can get it started but then
it is fun to to come back then and see
other people have added and improved and
so on and so forth and that idea of
collaborating you know where people can
much like open source software
um you know you you put your code out
and then people suggest revisions and
they change it and it modifies and it
grows beyond the original Creator
um it's just a kind of a fun wonderful
quite geeky hobby but
um people enjoy it how much debate was
there over the interface over the
details of how to make that well
seamless and frictionless yeah I mean
not as as much as there probably should
have been in a way during that two years
of the failure of newpedia where very
little work got done
what was actually productive was there
was a huge long discussion email
discussion very clever people talking
about things like neutrality talking
about what is an encyclopedia but also
talking about more technical ideas you
know things back then XML was kind of
all the rage and thinking about ah could
we
you know shouldn't you have certain uh
data that might be in multiple articles
that gets updated automatically so for
example you know the population of New
York City
every 10 years there's a new official
census couldn't you just up at the
update that bit of data in one place and
it would update across all those that is
a reality today but back then it was
just like how do we do that how do we
think about that so that is the reality
today where it's yeah there's some yeah
so the variables yeah wikidata um you
can you can link uh you know from a
Wikipedia entry you can link to that
piece of data in wikidata I mean it's a
pretty Advanced thing but there are
Advanced users who are doing that and
then when when that gets updated it
updates in all the languages where
you've done that I mean that's really
interesting there was this chain of
emails in the early days of discussing
the details of what is
so there's the interface there's the
yeah so the interface so an example
there was some software called use mod
wiki which we started with it's quite
amusing actually because the main reason
we launched with use mod wiki is that it
was a single Perl script so it was
really easy for me to install it on the
server and just get running but it was
um you know some guy's hobby project it
was cool but it was just a hobby project
and uh all the data was stored uh in
flat text files so there was no real
database behind it so that to search the
site you basically used graph which is
just like the basic Unix utility to like
look through all the files so that
clearly was never going to scale but
also in the early days it didn't have
real logins so you could set your
username but there were no passwords so
you know I might say Bob Smith and then
someone else comes along and says no I'm
Bob Smith and they both had it now that
never really happened we didn't have a
problem with it but it was kind of
obvious like you can't go a big website
where everybody can pretend to be
everybody that's that's not going to be
good for trust and reputation and so
forth so quickly I had to write a little
you know login you know store people's
passwords and things like that so you
can have unique identities and then
another example of something you know
quite you would have never thought would
have been a good idea and it turned out
to not be a problem but
to make a link in Wikipedia in the early
days
you would make a link to a page that may
or may not exist by just using camel
case meaning it's like uppercase
lowercase and you smash the words
together so maybe uh New York City you
might type any W no space capital Y York
City
and that would make a link but that was
ugly that was clearly not right and so I
was like okay well that that's just not
going to look nice let's just use square
brackets two square brackets makes a
link that may have been an option in the
software I'm not sure I thought up
Square broadcast but anyway we just did
that which worked really well it makes
nice links and you know you can see in
its red links or Blue Links depending on
if the page exists or not but the thing
that didn't occur to me even think about
is that for example on the German
language standard keyboard there is no
square bracket
so for German Wikipedia to succeed
people had to learn to do some alt codes
to get the square bracket or they a lot
of users cut and paste a square bracket
where they could find one they would
just cut and paste one in and yep German
Wikipedia has been a massive success so
somehow that didn't slow people down
um how is the the German keyboards don't
have a square bracket how do you do
programming how do you how do you live
it's life to its fullest very good
question I'm not really sure I mean
maybe it does now because of keyboard
standards have you know drifted over
time and becomes useful to have a
certain character I mean it's same thing
like there's not really a w character in
Italian
um and it wasn't on keyboards or I think
it is now but in in general W is not a
letter in Italian language but it
appears in enough International words
that it's crept into Italians and all of
these things are probably Wikipedia
articles in oh your cells oh yeah the
discussion is where brackets whole
discussion I'm sure on both the English
and the German Wikipedia and and
difference between those two might be
very uh uh very interesting